послання путіна я так це сприймаю
всьому світу в перших, звичайно, світовим
лідером як попередження того, що
загравати зі злочинцем чудовиськом
уособлюємо їм такий сучасний фашизм
виклик для всього світу го порядку та для
щоб розуміти що путін
нікому шансів не залишить і ось ці
уявні спроби якимось чином
домовитися вони ще більше зміцнюють
цього злочинця у своїх намірах
виконати ось цю шизофренічну ідею
збирання земель і насамперед це
стосується звичайно президента зеленського та
його командою які більше року
витратили на те щоб заспокоїти заколисати
обдурити суспільства в Україні, що росія
коли вони колись заз за свої
дії схаменутися і проситиме на
їй буде соромно так ось чіткі меседжі
сказані путіним
повинні протверезіти президента зелінського
і його оточення на нас чекає важкі часи
якщо ми зараз не згуртуємось і не дамо
чітка жорстка відповідь путіну своїми
діями і на фронті і mis ojos своїх
щодо криму не просто крим ми
ніколи не визнаємо окупацію, а те що
крим ми за нього боротимемося і
показати свої намір
досить чіткими щодо
окупації криму це і підтримувати наших
громадян в окупованому Криму це і
вести переговори з чіткими позиціями на
те, що це і відповідальність наших
партнерів за міжнародних і звичайно ж
це насамперед для нас
українців, що нам потрібно не скорочувати
збройні сили, а навпаки зараз ще
більше модель візувати ще більше
пояснювати, як ми робили всі ці п'ять років
що кожен наш воїн це наш наш
рятівник нас наш герой нашої держави
це люди, які ціною свого життя
забезпечують майбутнє України та
українського народу і що ми ніколи не
будемо скидати з рахунків
що у питанні до окупації крима буде
відігравати дуже важливу роль
наша армія наша сила не тільки
дипломатія тому що з таким
злочинцем одними дипломатичними
методами такими, які зараз застосовує
зелений його команда це скоріше шлях до
тому щоб втратити і саму Україну, що я
б ще хотів сказати кілька слів від
тих messenger які
доносить насамперед я вважаю нам
українцям путін це небажання
наших громадян у криму опинитися в такій
злочинні росії це це вимушене
сьогодні стані вільного українського
крима під окупацією
фашистської Росії наші громадяни кожен
день демонструє не прийняти її
окупації шляхом опору сотні
сидять у в'язницях та не припиняють боротьбу
знаючи чим загрожує цей опір
втратою життя втратою
багато років у в'язницях але боротьба буде
тільки наростати і
і ось для наших громадян у криму ось це
послання путіна злочинця трактується
однозначно
що ми ще більше групуватимемося
для того, щоб чинити опір
врятувати майбутнє наших дітей наших онуків
нашої нації